good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight turns out the symptoms
of societal decay are universal they're
not unique to a specific society you
recognize them in any country at any
time now or a thousand years ago always
the same the men become weak the leaders
get decadent law enforcement gets
politicized the currency gets devalued
and then things begin to come apart
pretty soon doesn't take long the
society can no longer perform its most
basic function the reason we have
societies in the first place which is to
protect the weak from the strong that's
why you have a society
well in places like this it becomes
among many other things very hard to
travel anywhere you just can't go where
you want to go with legitimate authority
in retreat
roads are not controlled by the police
they're controlled by armed predators
and the armed predators take exactly
what they want from travelers because
they can
this is an ancient problem it used to be
called highway robbery and for most of
history it kept people very close to
home
turns out it still exists but now it's
called carjacking
carjacking is the clearest possible sign
that your civilization is falling apart
and that's why you find it in places
like somalia and south africa places
where force violence and clan loyalty
have replaced law and order places where
might makes right
in the city of johannesburg for example
a vehicle is hijacked on average
once every hour of the day now once that
happens there's really no coming back
from it nobody's going to build anything
in a city with endemic carjacking in
fact most normal people will leave as
fast as they can as they have in
johannesburg as they are starting to do
we are sad to tell you in the city of
new orleans where carjacking is now a
permanent feature of life
last summer a law student called madison
bergeron pulled into the driveway of her
home in new orleans as she gathered her
belongings in the car a young man
appeared out of nowhere stuck a gun in
her face and demanded that she hand over
everything she had including the car he
screamed at her terrified she complied
and that's what carjacking is always
like it is an act of violence people
don't want to give up their cars they
have to be terrified into doing so
that's why the majority of victims are
women old women young women
and that's why the people who do it will
do anything if you will carjack if you
will steal someone's car at gunpoint you
will also rape you will also murder you
have no limits you are willing to
violate on the most basic level the
civil rights of another person and in
this case that was certainly true
because that same perpetrator went on
after terrifying madison bergeron and
stealing her car to do the same to other
women in the city a lot of them
there was a car blocking me in one
victim recalled and next thing i turn in
there's yelling and there's a gun barrel
in my face the kid is yelling to get the
f out of the car get the f out of the
car or else he will shoot me
in all the carjacker would terrorize
five women and steal five cars in just
two days
before new orleans police finally
arrested him and it's amazing that they
did because they're virtually no police
left in new orleans in a city that
probably needs about 2 000 cops there
are under 500 active duty policemen left
in new orleans in new orleans they have
definitely defunded the police
but in this case the carjacker a young
teenager was ultimately caught
tried convicted and sentenced for his
crimes now these crimes got a lot of
attention in new orleans so the mayor of
the city latoya cantrell showed up to
the sentencing but here's the twist in
the story
mayor cantrell didn't show up to support
the victims the women who'd been
terrorized by this predator no
the mayor showed up to support the
carjacker and to let the entire city
know that she was doing it to let
everyone know whose side she was on
watch
the mayor showed up in court as a
character witness for a 14 year old
offender during sentencing the teen
robbed three women in separate incidents
with a fake gun stealing their cars and
belongings the victims told fox 8 they
were traumatized by what happened and
then they felt victimized all over again
when the mayor showed up in support of
the young criminal
i was in shock she wasn't there for us
she was there
for
the assaultant and his mother and she
felt like she was supporting the crime
juvenile judge renard darrensburg
sentenced the juvenile to a three-year
suspended sentence meaning no jail time
it felt like she was supporting the
crime said the victim well yes it did
because that's exactly what the mayor
was doing cantrell was taking the side
of the carjacker over the
traumatized law-abiding woman
now in new orleans cantrell is known by
her nickname tidi but many people call
her exactly what she is latoya the
destroyer
she is in fact a destroyer the mayor is
incompetent mayor is an open race hater
the mayor is an encourager of violence
and she is destroying an already wounded
city
we reached out to mayor cantrell's
office to ask why she is doing all of
this why did she pressure a judge to
release a convicted armed carjacker with
no prison time but of course she didn't
reply to us it turns out the mayor of
new orleans had a connection to this
carjacker cantrell had enrolled this
person in one of her administration's
welfare programs called pathways youth
internship program using taxpayer money
the program says it provides young
people who commit crimes with a reward
paid internships and a stipend
we contacted the pathways program this
morning we want to know how many people
enrolled in that program go on to commit
violent crime within five years we also
asked how much taxpayer money they spend
but of course they didn't answer
but we don't need an answer we know
exactly what this is pathways like most
social justice scams is not in fact
designed to reduce crime
it's about siding with the criminal
giving the criminals as much support as
they need even a courtroom visit from
the mayor if necessary so they can go
out and commit more crimes as soon as
possible so why would you do something
like this if you were the mayor of a
city of new orleans why would you force
people to leave your city the people who
pay all the taxes of all colors by the
way
why would you do that
well possibly because the people who are
left
tend to be
the ones who vote for you so it is a
kind of electoral strategy it's not just
happening in new orleans it's happening
in a lot of places
the downside is it leads to carnage
there have already been 191 carjackings
in the city of new orleans this year
alone
through all of last year there were a
total of 177.
now most of these carjackings and this
is true in a lot of other places
washington dc we think most of these are
committed by people under the age of 18.
why because they know they'll get off
there's no cost the local station wwl tv
found that in 2021 juvenile carjacking
suspects outnumbered adults by more than
two to one now that doesn't mean that
these are nerf versions of carjackings
they're very violent in fact they're
always violent and sometimes they're
fatal
in march several juveniles aged 15 to 17
mutilated the body of a grandmother an
elderly woman as they carjacked her in
mid-city new orleans they dragged her
body down the street
here's fox 8 new orleans reporting on it
17-year-old john honore 16-year-old
branaya baker and 15-year-olds markel
curtis and lynn lenrya theophile will be
tried as adults on second-degree murder
charges police say that the teens
carjacked linda fricke in mid-city back
in march fricke was beat and then
dragged outside of her car until her arm
was eventually severed from her body she
then bled to death in the middle of the
street
so again society exists not to protect
17-year-olds with guns on the most basic
level those are the strongest people in
society people willing to use force to
get what they want no
society exists to protect people who
need the protection
the helpless the weak
grandmothers who might be dragged and
have their arms ripped off without
police protection and of course in the
absence of police protection and in the
absence of leadership that cares about
the weak those are exactly the person
who are people who are murdered
and it's not just happening in new
orleans what's interesting if you pull
back a little bit and we have because we
think that carjacking is a really clear
indication of things unraveling you find
that cities with soros-backed das and
well-funded diversion programs for
at-risk youth
are seeing surges
in car jackets could there be a
connection
philadelphia for example consider that
city this is reporting from the local
station there fox 29
jackings in philly a crime that's been
exploding over the last several months
and according to philly police numbers
released to steve keely by a source it's
getting worse from january 1st of this
year through july 31st a police source
says there have been
757 carjackings citywide there were
roughly 850 carjackings in all of 2021
the latest sourced police statistics
showed that the majority of these
carjackings more than 500 happened at
gunpoint and also happened while the
victims were at their parked cars
so why is this happening well it's
happening for very deep reasons
any 15 or 17 year old who sticks a gun
in the face of strangers threatens their
lives or kills them in order to steal a
car
is the product of something that is very
hard to fix disintegrating families
that's the real reason but society the
authorities still have an
obligation to try and stop it for the
sake of the rest of us so what are these
cities doing to stop it well
philadelphia like new orleans sends
so-called at-risk youth to
violin lessons through something called
the philadelphia arts and education
partnership so the idea is after a month
of violin lessons
these young criminals people who've been
busted committing crimes get their
records expunged that was the plan that
philadelphia's d.a put into place last
year
has it worked well sad to tell you that
despite the violin lessons crime has
gone up among young people carjackings
in particular as philadelphia's police
commissioner daniel outlaw put a quote i
don't want to say it's surprising
but it's definitely concerning really
well it's not surprising to us but it is
for sure an understatement from 2020 to
2021 there's been a 108 percent increase
in carjackings in philadelphia chicago
too putting up similar numbers chicago
has had more than a thousand carjackings
this year alone
what does that do to a city a thousand
carjackings
for every carjacking there is a much
larger group of people
now afraid to drive
now chicago is the place where soros
back d.a kim fox recently implemented
something called the juvenile
intervention and support center right
for this initiative fox partnered with
them we're quoting black owned black run
businesses called chi by design which
pledges to quote be bold in our
collaborative approach to create
anti-racist outcomes
really so it's been completely
politicized
the point of law enforcement
traditionally has been to enforce the
law laws that are passed by legislatures
as opposed to the democratic process in
order to protect everybody else
now the point of law enforcement is to
affect anti-racist outcomes in other
words political outcomes
how's that working in chicago well
here's fox 32 chicago to tell you
there's a carjacked car
chicago we got eyes on it one of the
passengers in the stolen suv eventually
fled when police caught him they
discovered he was 17 years old released
to his mother
sadly he's not the youngest suspect that
members of the carjacking task force
have seen
a well-known 11 year old
that have been in contact with police
before
yes yes an 11 year old was arrested in
chicago as part of a carjacking crew and
it was not his first time
11 years old
one of that carjacked her victim said
that quote he actually skipped like a
child all the way up to the car he stole
we can't tell you his name because he's
an at-risk risk youth apparently needs
more violin lessons and he will soon be
a productive member of society this is a
joke the people administering the
program know it's a joke
it doesn't achieve the main overriding
goal which is to protect people who just
want to go to the grocery store to
protect grandmothers who want to go to
church protect everybody else who wants
to go to work in the morning who wants
to live in a city where you can travel
on the roads without being killed
chicago's leaders don't care the same is
true by the way of the unnamed 16 year
old girl who hijacked a man's audi while
his child was in the car
that's an atrocity
here's fox's 32 in chicago
now 6-0 east 23rd child's in the car the
frantic father reports his car stolen
somebody jumped into his black audi q7
with the dealer plate his child is in
the car
so as you so often see in these cases
the person who commits the crime has
committed a ton of other crime because
it turns out most crimes are committed
by a very small number of people and in
this case the girl who stole that car
stole several other cars that month
which makes you wonder maybe violin
lessons and visits in the courtroom from
the mayor
don't really work maybe these people
need a father at home the nuclear family
right
those things are not in fact racist they
are essential to any functioning
civilization and in lieu of them it is
clear
that things fall apart
and the only thing you can do is to put
people
out
of the public sphere away
so that other people aren't hurt by them
that's the best we can do and it's
obligatory that we do it because people
are being killed
if you don't do that you wind up with a
society in which 11 year olds treat
carjacking like a sport because they
know they can get out of jail very
quickly here's fox 2 in detroit
police arrested an 11 12 and 14 year old
for stealing high-end hellcats off the
jefferson north lot
they think it's fun you know they think
it's fun and there's no penalty to it
head of the detroit police commercial
auto theft unit lieutenant clive stewart
stunned over the trio of kids arrested
monday right here on the storage line of
the jefferson north plant in a separate
incident this kid just 14 years old an
alleged repeat carjacker arrested this
weekend he was out on bond from a
carjacking in may then last week police
say he jacked two cars on the city's
east side the same night
so if you look closely enough at this
specific problem carjacking and it's one
of many problems in our society that
seem to be getting worse but just look
at this one and you begin to realize
because everything is irony at this
point the youth violence prevention
initiatives are supposed to stop this
actually enable it indeed appear to be
encouraging it and yet they're still
getting millions of dollars from the
bide administration
the youth diversion programs that make
these kinds of crimes more common have a
lot in common with the equity programs
for unhoused people that seem to
encourage homelessness
those two have led to more carjackings
here's a report from fox 11 in l.a
carjacking caught on camera witnesses
keeping their distance as a homeless man
punches a street vendor then steals his
van
the street vendor was carjacked by a
homeless man over the weekend
esteban says he'd even seen his attacker
before and that he had never had a
problem with him adding that he gave the
man food shortly before he punched him
in the face
yeah
so if they're happening in new orleans
in los angeles and chicago of course
this is happening in our biggest city
new york which is also run by yet
another soros d.a
but as evidence of the collapse of
social order is in philadelphia detroit
la and las vegas nowhere in the country
is experiencing a bigger increase in
carjackings
then the birthplace of our new civil
rights movement minneapolis where this
all started according to the national
insurance crime bureau minneapolis saw
the largest percent increase in
carjackings in the country from 2019 to
2021 a 339 percent jump
what the hell is going on and why is no
one saying anything about it and why are
these cities doing nothing to stop it
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight